the coronavirus has reached one of the
most secure structures in the world the
white house people working with US
President Donald Trump have been
instructed to wear face masks that after
two aids tested positive for kovat 19
now the virus has so far killed more
than 80,000 people in the US the new
infections at the White House come as
the president pressures state governors
to relax pandemic restrictions a swift
change in attitude as the White House
scrambles to prevent the corona virus
from spreading among employees everyone
entering the West Wing where the
president works must wear a face mask
that is almost everyone president Donald
Trump has refrained from wearing a mask
in public in private and says he still
doesn't see the need there certain
distance from me or there a certain
distance from each other they do in the
case of me I'm not it I'm not close to
anybody I'd like to be close to these
two gentlemen they're hard-working great
men but they just said frankly let's
keep it this way so obviously in my case
I'm very far away from everyone the new
face mask directive comes after two
staffers tested positive for kovat 19
Katie Miller the spokeswoman for vice
president Mike Pence and one of
President Trump's own valley's pence is
now in South isolation along with three
other high-profile members of the
government's coronavirus task force they
include leading epidemiologist dr.
Anthony Fauci the face of the
administration's response officials at
the White House say that staffers are
being tested regularly but employees and
reporters working in the West Wing have
been voicing concerns over their safety
the West Wing is a very old cramped
workspace lots of small offices next to
one another some of them don't even have
windows the ones that do have windows
I'm not even certain they can open the
windows for fresh air because of
security concerns and everyone is
passing each other in these narrow
hallways going back and forth to
multiple meetings every day
as officials try to contain the virus
within the White House President Trump
is continuing to urge US states to
reopen their economies despite many
wondering if it's all still too soon
earlier we spoke with DW correspondent
Stefan Siemens about whether the US
economy can reopen with all this
uncertainty about the spread of the
virus that's the key question in across
the country how do you restart the
economy if you a don't know really how
widespread the virus is be as soon as
you open the country up a little bit
local communities open up for business
again and States open up for business
again and the numbers are then in a
trajectory up north again so there is no
there's a trust issue of course people
need to believe that they are safe
before they go to work otherwise
nobody's going to work and you do not
open the economy then so that's the core
the the big problem here for the
president and everybody involved with
solving this problem
Stefan Siemens there
well among those at the forefront of the
struggle to contain the pandemic or
nurses and since today is International
Nurses Day we're focusing on the
sacrifices that they've been making to
save lives our next report starts with a
look at the woman credited with creating
the modern profession Florence
Nightingale today also marks her birth
200 years ago
the original queen of Hygiene Florence
Nightingale she revolutionized
battlefield medicine during the Crimean
War when more British soldiers were
dying of infections than battle wounds
the principles remain is just exactly
the same today as they did 200 years ago
which is you need to wash your hands and
you need to make sure that the
environment you work in is incredibly
clean and tidy and importantly the space
between patients and the need for
ventilation
the corona virus pandemic has
overwhelmed hospitals around the world
that's led many nurses to protest from
Peru to Washington DC outside the White
House in Senegal this nurse says there's
a strong sense of duty in the profession
we have no choice
from the moment you set out to become a
nurse to practice this profession I
think it's a source of pride to be a
nurse to be able to help people to be
able to help them recover their health
one person who does appreciate nurses
Street artist Banksy whose latest work
game-changer is on display at a London
hospital
[Music]
and we're joined now by the European
Federation of nurses associations
secretary-general Paul de rabe from
Brussels thanks so much for being with
us Paul let me thank you and everyone in
your profession for all you've been
doing during this crisis an estimated
179 health care staff in Britain alone
have died during this pandemic many of
them nurses what's the biggest risk that
they're facing in this pandemic
I think the pandemic came to us quite
suddenly so many member states in the
European Union including the Commission
itself was not prepared for this and as
such the protection equipment that we
need to have in order to go next to the
patient to watch the patients who feed
the patient to nurse the patient was not
available so even from the Ebola crisis
in 2014 yes and wrote a report at that
time the title was we are not prepared
unless we are all prepared and in that
report yet and made clear
recommendations please government's give
your nurses your physicians who are
frontline who are taking care of the
patients that BP eats the masks the
materials that they need to protect
themselves and I think everybody trying
to do their best
okay now Paul that report was a six
years ago calling for protection
equipment what went wrong why did
national governments why did the
European Commission Brussels not listen
to your call for help I think in that
time the Luxembourg summit on health was
that preparedness and Ebola crisis you
know we had a few nurses who came to
London to Madrid who were affected who
came from from Africa but you know this
pandemic is totally different has a
totally different scale and to
government's by surprise also the lack
of coordination
you know the Commission has no there is
still this subsidiarity principle and
you know in relation to health
governments has always said yes but this
is not your responsibility until you
have a serious problem and then you miss
out on the time so we have always said
please make sure that the 16
recommendations that are in that report
they are suitable today and we are not
asking much we just ask the things that
we need to do our job properly and to
not put ourselves at risk you think it'd
be very simple to get masks and gloves
to the people who need it most Paul
thank you so very much we have to leave
it there thank you for all your work and
we'd like to recognize you on this
International Nurses Day and all the
people in your profession Paul thank you
so thank you be welcome well our next
report now Indonesia has suffered Asia's
second highest death toll from kovat 19
behind China and in the past six weeks
the partial lock downs to prevent the
spread of the corona virus have cost
more than 2 million Indonesians their
jobs now to help its citizens overcome
these hard times the government's
turning to a novel form of social
welfare this isn't your typical ATM
machine instead of cash it pumps out
another valuable commodity rice for free
the one and a half kilo rice rations
help these residents near Jakarta who
are struggling to make ends meet because
of the corona virus I was laid off by my
company last week and my husband was
laid off too without severance pay
although it isn't a lot it's still very
helpful
those eligible are given special rice
ATM cards which they can take to the
dispenser to collect their daily ration
of rice every day we prepare one and a
half tons of rice for around a thousand
residents multiply that by two months
we'll continue doing it every day
without rest even on weekends we will
keep distributing according to the
government the pandemic has set back its
efforts to eradicate poverty by an
entire decade restrictions are being
eased to allow markets like this one in
Central Java to reopen even though it's
still not clear if Indonesia's kovat 19
curve has been sufficiently flattened
what is certain is that initiatives like
this rice ATM are needed to keep those
who are struggling from going hungry
like other European nations Spain has
started easing some of its restrictions
restaurants hotels museums and some
cities are now allowed to cautiously
reopen but many regions are still locked
down the government says almost half the
country is yet to meet the criteria for
lock downs to be lifted and even in
cities that have been given the green
light while business owners are very
cautious we have this from Sevilla this
is the first time in two months that
Joaquin Antonio has opened his doors he
stands at his coffee machine at 7:00 in
the morning just like he has in the last
28 years ever since his father opened
the cafe in the centre of Seville but
things are very different now new
regulations state he can only serve
customers outside with half as many
tables as usual nonetheless Antonia
hopes a few patrons become or his cafe
might not survive the last few months
have been really tough we had operating
costs but absolutely no income state
assistance helped but it's still just a
loan we have to pay it all back and
somehow keep our business afloat
we have to try at least to be honest
it's all very depressing Seville
fulfills all the criteria to qualify for
an easing of social restrictions a low
rate of infections and a good supply of
hospital beds that puts it at a better
footing than the capital Madrid but many
civil businesses will still stay closed
this time of year is peak season for
Antonio Romero specialty cooked snails
but currently at his restaurant he
hasn't even set out the tables he's
running a small delivery service but had
to lay off his whole staff is frustrated
by a lack of clear information from the
government we were just told okay
from today on you can open again but up
until the day before they told us they
didn't publicly announce anything about
what that meant and exactly what
regulations would have to be met besides
restaurants small businesses and hotels
are being allowed to open this week at
least on paper
many shopkeepers also keep their
businesses closed due to the strict
regulations some have already given up
empty shop windows and for rent signs
are becoming more and more common in
Spanish city centres Spain is one of the
countries most affected by the crisis at
all levels while pictures of overcrowded
hospitals are only a few weeks old the
latest economic figures are causing new
horror experts are warning of
unemployment rates of more than 30
percent Becket Joaquin Antonio's cafe
the terrace is slowly beginning to fill
up he's been able to reemployed Riojas
for masta he's hoping the next easing of
restrictions might mean he can soon
invite customers inside to join now by
the correspondent who filed that report
for us John Philip Schultz good morning
to you in Sevilla young Philip II first
off more than half of Spain returned to
a semblance of normality today or
yesterday rather but half the country is
still on lockdown yes that's true but
still for the people here in Spain
it's been a youths that it might seem
still strict compared to other countries
but we have to keep in mind that until
some days ago all of Spain was under the
strictest lockdown in all of Europe so
the new rules that are out now
they include besides the opening of
restaurants that we saw the report they
also include a relaxation of measures on
a personal level for example people can
meet in small groups again and what is
very interesting about the Spanish model
is that each region has to apply for a
relaxation of measure method measures
and then the central government decides
that region can move on or if a region
has two waves
okay so handing a lot of the
responsibility for reopening down to the
lowest level that's the the most local
level that sounds like a good idea or
what do people think of the loosening of
the measures in general I think in
general people welcome the easing of of
measures because it's been very tougher
than for more than two months now you
can see a lot of families out on the
streets now strolling around you can see
people having a drink on the streets so
people are generally welcoming the steps
but we also have to keep in mind that
Spain is still very heavily affected the
memories of overcrowded hospitals are
still very fresh in the memories of the
people so the people welcome the steps
but they are still cautious at the same
time okay they're still cautious right
now but what are the next steps
especially regarding the big cities like
Madrid Barcelona the other regions
they're still under tight restrictions
exactly Barcelona and Madrid they are
still under tighter restrictions because
there are infection rates are still very
high so they cannot move on to the
further levels of relaxation when the
head of the local government in Madrid
tried to relax the restrictions she
received huge protests a lot of her
colleagues
from other regions protested and said
that the capital should not get special
treatment just because it's the capital
of the country so there are still a lot
of discussions ahead but what is for
sure is that many regions can move on to
the next level in two weeks and this
will also include the opening of cinemas
and theaters
okay-y unfold thanks so much for that
update from Sevilla and for your report
as well today we're taking a look now
some of the other developments in the
corona virus pandemic a new outbreak of
corona virus cases in South Korea has
been linked to a man who visited a
number of night clubs while infected the
number of related new cases has now
surpassed 100 Germany is also seeing a
rise in new infections after some
relaxation of lockdown restrictions the
government will contribute 750 million
euros to develop a new vaccine and after
the first day of eased restrictions in
France that country also reporting an
increase this one in deaths from the
virus on Monday